did the movie become what you had first
envisioned or once you got into the
editing room it became its own different
story huh yeah it always happens in my
films especially but it's sort of
sometimes linear narrative becomes
nonlinear for I've done it in a couple
places in the phone but otherwise when I
finished the script I didn't tell anyone
the whole story had to be told and I
thought it's too long to say as a film
so I made up my mind that I'm going to
make two films so this is the first one
I've already done ten percent of the
second floor that's how much I pin my
help on the script and that's why Barry
like the idea because he he bet on three
films Barry husband so a lot of the
Rings trilogy so I think that's the
confidence I had in what I had on paper
and a paper could mean anything it could
just be an artistic dream that
everything is looking beautiful but then
I had some time to mull over it and I
didn't tell anyone I just gave the first
piece to everyone and they liked it and
then I told him I got my crew into
confidence and said I'm gonna make one
more would it be interested in being
part of that and they were and we shot
some more after the main shadi rule was
completed
you